[Music]
thank you very much everyone and thank
you for coming to what promises to be a
really fascinating debate with a great
group of panelists whom i will introduce
in a minute but first of all just to
talk about the theme of the debate
rationality which was once revered has
had a bit of a bad press
it's increasingly derided as the
rhetorical bluster of an educated elite
most typically white and male
and as a
prejudice claim of those who are sure
that they're in the right
yet the absence in the absence of reason
public debate risks becoming ever more
rancorous and tribal
so do we need less emotion more calm and
more rational conversation and debate
should we see rationality as a method
for positive change and a mechanism for
good decision making
or is rationality in fact a rhetorical
delusion a means of dressing up
privilege and power which should be seen
for what it is a defense of the vested
interests it seeks to hide
well
let's ask all these speakers i'm going
to introduce them all nina power is a
cultural critic social theorist
philosopher and translator
formerly a senior lecturer in philosophy
at roehampton university nina's interest
are in philosophy art feminism and
politics
timothy williamson i'm allowed to call
him tim apparently is the wiccan
professor of logic at the university of
oxford
uh his most eminent works include the
philosophy of philosophy and knowledge
and its limits
that's very meta
[Laughter]
and sophie archer is a distinguished
academic specialising in the philosophy
of mind psychology and epistemology she
was the robin geffen research fellow and
tutor in philosophy at the university of
oxford and now lectures at the
university of cardiff
so a three-minute pitch from each of
them because they're all academics i've
decided to say to them we've got to
define our terms what do we mean by
rationality
tim over to you
yeah well i think
some philosophers have a rather
narrow conception of of rationality as
um
sort of based on calculation some kind
of formal consistency uh and that seems
to me
way too narrow and a very inadequate way
of thinking what it is i mean roughly
speaking um the way i think of
rationality it's
um
some kind of openness to getting new
evidence and
um and
disposition to to act and to form
beliefs in ways that are appropriate
given uh your evidence and
and that's that's something
that that i would uh see as coming in
degrees and so that you know adults are
typically um
more rational than
two-year-old children
um the two-year-old children are not
totally uh lacking in
uh in rationality um and
um
i would even think of
rationality as something that
can be found in you know in somewhat
primitive forms in in many
non-human uh animals i mean so that for
example you know when you you think of a
predator um hunting a prey i mean they
they're both
typically you know they've got to be
able to to act in some way in the light
of their evidence i mean their evidence
about where the other animal
is and about you know about where
what there is in their environment stuff
to hide behind and all those kind of
things and you know so if they're if
they were acting in
uh completely irrational ways which paid
no attention to their evidence uh that
they're not likely to withstand the the
test of evolution uh for for very long
so so this is it's actually an extremely
widespread phenomenon over a whole range
of species of course with human
rationality we've got we've got language
and we can use language to
uh you know reflect in ex explicit sort
of ways about our evidence and and and
that enables us to be to be rational in
in much more
uh sophisticated
uh ways to to recognize you know the
ways in in which our sort of initial
instincts may may actually be mistaken
and then we can correct them
but and so that's as it were an extra
layer of rationality that that we have
that isn't available in the same way to
creatures that don't have language but
basically we're just talking about
different levels of something that is uh
extremely widespread amongst living
creatures
great thank you nina
yeah i guess first of all i'd say that
everybody thinks
and i'd be very wary of anyone who would
say
otherwise
and in that sense i think we have to
understand that everybody has reasons
for the claims that they make
and i think it's often very disingenuous
when we seek to
present our opponents if you like as
being motivated by extra rational
concerns alone so and this often happens
in particularly emotive debates where we
seek to assert that the other person is
motivated by something malicious they're
motivated by hate perhaps
whereas if you actually want to have a
dialogue with somebody you have to
assume uh something like the principle
of charity which is that basically the
person
argument has they have good reasons for
why they're claiming what they claim and
you argue against that and i think we
need to have more of an understanding of
the uh sort of necessity and reality of
dialogue and the fact that people give
different reasons for different
positions and that everybody
thinks is basically a fundamental
axiom at the same time i think it's very
difficult to think for oneself even
though that seems very obvious that this
is something we all
grant ourselves
it's actually very difficult to
find out sometimes what it is that we
actually think about a particular issue
we're surrounded by opinion and doxa and
kind of a whole confusing
array of information and it often takes
time to work through
an idea or an argument and i think
reason is one of those things that helps
us to think it's not everything
i do think though that reason and
emotion for example shouldn't be opposed
if you read someone like spinoza he says
that basically emotion and this these
ideas of these kind of feelings that
they're also amenable to comprehension
so that we can actually um get a bigger
picture of why we feel the way we do why
we feel for example envy towards someone
why we feel confusion in another context
we can actually
access reason to talk about emotions so
i wouldn't necessarily oppose reason and
emotion
either
i would say that a narrow image of
rationality for example the idea that
human beings are only fundamentally
calculating uh for example like economic
rationality
is not
the sum total of how we think about
things and so i would also defend the
idea of reason as having a speculative
element which is to say asking questions
that we can't immediately answer maybe
asking questions that are very grandiose
asking questions about the cosmos about
the nature of our soul about whether god
exists or not whether our soul is
immortal you know kant talks about
reason as basically pushing us to ask
questions that we can't answer so i
think reason also has this kind of
cosmic speculative
philosophical uh dimension and it's not
always going to be able to solve those
questions but it kind of pushes us
to ask them
and in that sense i think it's very it's
something very beautiful and something
that we can engage in together in
dialogue and this is in a way what
philosophical dialogue
is all about is reasoning together it's
not something that we can necessarily
only do on our own even at the same time
as we want to try to understand what it
is that we actually think about any
particular issue so i think there should
be more reason i think that everyone has
reason i think that everyone can give
reasons and we should be able to talk
about everything that matters to us
without being shut down
so you're using reason as a synonym for
rationality here um yeah i mean if there
are
we could talk about complicated
definitions but yes let's say for the
sake of this conversation okay great
thank you sophie
hi um so i think that sometimes by
rationality people mean something like
responding well to reasons
and if that's what we mean by
rationality then i think
that it's pretty clear that human beings
don't do that most of the time
in fact we're kind of notoriously
irrational
so you know we believe things because we
want to believe them rather than because
the evidence suggests that they're true
um so apparently
90 some percent of people um believe
that they're more beautiful
and more intelligent than average um
which are better drivers too
yeah yeah which obviously can't be true
for all of us um and we're also
massively practically irrational as well
so you know we
uh sincerely resolve to give up smoking
and then half an hour later we're
lighting up the next cigarette right so
we're massively irrational
um so if by rationality we mean
something like responding well to
reasons then i think it's clear that
we're not very rational for the most
part in that sense
um however there's another sense
of rationality i think
um where
it is more reasonable to say that we are
rational which is that we have the
capacity to respond to reasons right if
by being rational we mean that someone
has the capacity to respond to reasons
then ironically enough all of that
irrationality
only serves to establish that we are
rational in that other sense right that
we have the capacity to respond to
reasons
because we wouldn't be able to be
irrational that is to say we wouldn't be
able to exercise that capacity poorly
unless we had that capacity um so that's
the distinction between two
senses of rationality
and i'll leave it there for now okay to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas
you